he's marc-andre flurries a well
decorated goalie certainly from his days
in Pittsburgh and maybe another
opportunity here for Stanley covering
the Vegas Golden Knights goalie joins us
now how are you today
yeah not bad but you know I'm not facing
pucks like you do for a living
do you ever did you ever get used to
like just the speed that the the feeling
of taking those pucks yeah with practice
and even when you get injured or
something and you come back like it
feels bad then all that absolute
practice is nothing you kind of get your
time in back and I think you can sort of
it where's the worst place to get hit
five whole family duel yeah but you have
protection there right yeah it's a cop
right you protective Cup yeah okay you
probably didn't think you were gonna get
these kind of questions there mark so on
okay
did you did you ever want to be like a
goal scorer throwing up my second best
option was to be goalie but who did you
want to be like what what hockey player
did you map a turn your offensive skills
after minutes and goalies with the path
equal or more Jupiter from Jersey when
did you know you were good and a goalie
I never thought I would make it actually
to the NHL they always seem to do far
away and to people are too good and also
I think when I first took my first NHL
game maybe that's when I realized I
could
be good enough yes do you hate like
other scores yeah you do
yeah like who do you really hate animal
guys that scores a lot you know just
everything has their own liquor I think
good defenses guys you know I think even
in practice though sometime I hate my
forward who talks trash to you my player
in the players Belmar Marsha so what do
they say a little bit Allah that's good
let me know when it goes in do you do
you trash talk in French yeah comes more
naturally maybe it'll more let's say
let's say I just came in it's just you
against me and you stoned me and and and
you don't like me in French what do you
say to me whoa we could you I could we
could start fighting after that wouldn't
we no no cuz then practice has to stop
and then you gotta get your gloves and
all that so then it's justified no all
right are you are you friends with other
goalies you guys are you all in the same
fraternity I would say so yeah I feel
like I've met guys over the years right
at different places and it's always cool
to you know meet them pick up their
brains a bit and I feel like you you
know I'm a bit by just from watching all
the games and because there's a goalie
too but explain to me whenever there's a
fight it feels like we wait for the
goalies to fight each other like that
why can't you just pick on you know some
score like a center or something why do
you have to go all the way to the other
end of the ice mark
because the fight will be little bit
unfair you know cuz we get too much gear
on and then it's tough to remove and and
bunch of it you know I think before
that's a little advantage allah are you
good - do magic though i thought twice
in junior I think maybe I have a winner
ty if I told you at the beginning of the
year you guys are playing for the cop
what would you said to me
I've been little skeptical maybe but how
surprised are you that you guys who
played this well the the fan reaction
how Vegas is embraced you guys I mean
it's a pretty amazing story you know
there's so many unknowns coming to Vegas
right about to make a team here and it's
crazy how much we got how much support
we got from the fans and we have to
create group of guys great chemistry and
within winning game and all but another
part have you brought out your Stanley
Cup rings for the guys to see from your
days in Pittsburgh no Pittsburgh they
gave they gave mind from that era so
they got to see it that was and you were
in Pittsburgh what 13 12 13 years yep
did you did you face them you and
practice a little bit tougher Lemieux or
Crosby I think Mario was this more
innovative and first practice I did with
him I made a save one time and I kept
the talk of - did you get him to sign it
that's awesome
you didn't you didn't do that to a
Sidney Crosby though no no serious
competitor in practice though thank you
always
it doesn't stop you always keep coming
back and likes to admit he yells at you
before yeah I wouldn't call it that you
know are you watching Game seven tonight
yeah yeah sure what would you get do you
take notes not so much I think it's just
as a fan then you look at the game say
it's good hockey it's fun to watch and
then we know who we're gonna play but
you don't take anything away from you
know watching you won't learn anything
from Ovechkin if Washington advances
there'd be nothing that you'd go okay
I'm going to remember that
I think the opponent's also gonna call
this a team you know uh maybe a little
bit yeah you look at the players
tendencies out there but most of the
video stuff we do it as a team
along with Doris coordinator report we
have a request here when you guys win
the Cup I'm not asking for a playoff
share or anything like that I've been
with you guys all season long I'm not
asking for you know the mask or a jersey
or a stick or anything marked you know
what I want just one thing I'd like to
have your protective Cup from the
Stanley Cup final the cup from and
winning the is that is that is that too
much to ask for mark okay well you guys
are you guys are superstitious here so I
don't want to I don't want to break a
good streak but you know I can go Sox if
I if I can't get your protective cup
then we can do Sox but you know I don't
want what everybody else wants mark all
right but don't keep me in mind during
any of the games I want you to focus on
the game itself all right we'll wait
till after you guys win the Cup but
always protect your five-hole mark okay
yeah all right that's the mark Andre
flurry thank you and good luck
my goaltender for more Dan Patrick show
to the audio
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]